hello everyone i'm minus carlson from
norway
chess world champion since 2013.
i'm going to break down a couple of
games from the
queen's gambit series so please enjoy
[Music]
at this moment morgeth has generally
done
done quite well um he
has uh created something of an
initiative on uh on the king side
um and uh all his
his uh his pieces are pretty pretty
actively uh
actively placed but beth is also
is also playing uh playing quite uh
quite well
um centralizing her her pieces bringing
her knights uh into into the game
but at the moment he is the one who
uh who is pressing and uh she is the one
who has to concern herself
with um with equalizing the the game
yeah she kicks away the queen from uh
from an aggressive position there um
very important
important move
here uh burgov makes a huge mistake
here he essentially has only one uh
decent move that he can play which means
that she will be
able to predict his his next move and
she knows
uh what she has to prepare for and here
we can see
borgoff makes the makes the obvious move
and
it is no surprise to her and she um
she has prepared the the best the the
best reply
um knight to e6 i have to sit
to say that he responds
really poorly this is something that
should not happen
bergoth has a whole night to prepare
and he makes not an obvious mistake
but not a mistake you should make when
you've had that
time to uh to prepare what's happened
here
uh is that she makes absolutely the best
move
there by moving her knight into a
dangerous position
and what borgov needed to realize there
is that however much he wants to win the
game
he can't win the game he has to chop off
that knight
move his rook in order to to take out
beth's
most dangerous pawns and basically lick
with
liquidate the game towards a draw yes
that is not what he wants
but you have to be realistic there this
particular sequence
she handles like a true champion and
he handles he handles it like a uh
yeah like like a like a desperate man
so the sequence here is is is really
beautiful
uh she sacrifices a pawn but
basically ties up all borogov's
pieces
he's not doing what he's supposed to do
and all the excitement from the public
here
uh i find a bit nonsensical because
she she's winning and she knows it
and he should know it and the others
should should realize it's it's not it's
not
obvious but it should be fairly clear
that his pieces are tied up and
and so despite him being upon pawn up at
this point
she definitely has all the chances now
she she can look she can look up at the
sky
uh at the ceiling as much as she wants
but she knows it she knows she's winning
i feel like she's just torturing
him at this point which she has every
which has every
she has every right to do of course i
just see the
the chessboard uh in in my head so i
might look
look away um like like you're trying to
remember
something or look up
which is also like looking away and
looking up is usually
a sign that you're trying to remember
something but no uh the pieces are not
there on
on the ceiling they're just just in my
head
[Music]
she's playing quite precisely there
moving moving the queen but there were
already
uh plenty of ways to to win there
[Music]
uh she makes a very good positional move
there
fortifying her um her bishop
and this
uh draw offer is frankly insulting
she she should never take it
uh as i said his pieces are all tied up
she uh she can never lose and
um you should never offer a draw in this
situation like
you may offer a draw in a worse position
where you have counter chances
he doesn't have any counter chances here
she absolutely needs to
um to reject this particular
particular offer
[Music]
he moves the the king away and she
sacrifices the queen
very very beautiful full choice there
she had other ways to win as well
but this is a fitting way to
kind of humiliate him and to punish him
for
his uh his indecent
offer of uh overdraw
[Music]
so now she she is a bishop up
she's getting a new queen and she just
has to make
sure that he doesn't get some miracle
counter play with his queen and his rook
but she's figured
everything out she she calculates so
well that this is
this is easy for her
she moves her rook back uh he has only
he sacrificed the rook
he's only a queen left she has a little
smile
uh knowing that borgoff he should have
conceded before
but she knows that he has to concede he
has to resign now
borgroff shouldn't smile he should be
ashamed
at the way he conducted the end of the
this game um she uh he made a lot of
mistakes but uh uh he is uh
correct in acknowledging that the fact
that she
she played extremely well in general i
felt like
the chess was very very well done uh
in the series lots of game segments that
i'd never seen
never seen before and they were
they were quite quite pretty uh as well
and watching the series uh i would
several
times like try and predict what was
going gonna happen and then
um when i was realizing yeah that there
it is that's that's the combination they
want to show
uh was really it's really exciting as um
as not only a chess player but as uh as
a massive chess fan as well
i hope you guys enjoy enjoyed these
little bits
from beth harmon's games and
go out and play have fun